ironically most of us are so afraid of
being alone that we actually end up
isolating ourselves trying to prevent it
we all want the world to like us we all
want to be the best we can be this is a
noble goal to have but when we are so
fearful that people won't like us we
begin to put effort towards something
that is intrinsically effortless we
begin to relinquish our confidence and
personality to a character manufactured
out of fear and insecurity if we truly
want others to enjoy being around you
you must first dedicate your effort to
learning how to accept and enjoy
yourself by caring less about how others
feel about you and more about how you
feel about yourself you often become a
much more likeable person your presence
will be honest and real it will be
infectious
people will see you rather than three
people who try to make others like them
before they like themselves act only out
of insecurity and fear and ultimately
all their attempts at real connection
lead back to insecurity and fear for
example in a conversation often the
harder you try the less successful you
are at maintaining fluidity and
enjoyable Ness a person who simply seeks
to be themselves will be both confident
and comfortable
if you are educated to any degree and
have lived at all you have a unique and
valuable perspective of the world if you
embrace and trust in it you do not have
to work at being any character other
than your own a combination of Socrates
philosophy know thyself and Emerson's
trust thyself appear to solve many of
the common social problems that humans
face both quotes are based on thyself
and this is no coincidence
thy self is the foundation to all
personal experiences even when they
involve others one who tries to avoid
inadequate social interactions will
almost certainly create them one who is
concerned that they are not going to
always say the right thing will almost
certainly say the wrong thing one who
simply is is and will always be a happy
and beautiful contributor to social
exchange
do not let your imagination create
social problems that do not exist the
only purpose for sociality is to learn
teach connect or have fun conversations
and relationships take on a life of
their own and you must let them fulfill
their purpose when you cease to solely
identify with your social interactions
and instead let them identify with you
they will be vibrant and wondrous
you
you